oh je voudrais tout d'abord signalé aux
téléspectateurs qui n'ont pas suivi
depuis quelques temps cette remarquable
mission sur le courrier des shadoks que
nous essayons dans toute la mesure du
possible de leur rendre service et
supprimer cette émission qui
effectivement est navrante si on en juge
par les lettres
alors madame par exemple tu iras rue
saint-martin condé sur noireau dans le
14ème dit la télévision est ferait mieux
de nous laisser dans le noir complet
pour le grand bien de nos yeux et nos
nerfs bien écoutez madame ça ça n'est
pas possible parce que vous savez que
vous payez très très cher une redevance
qu'il faut absolument qu'on vous donne
quelque chose en compensation alors nous
voulons bien remplacer les shadoks mais
il faut trouver quelque chose qui marque
le coup qu'ils soient énormes est
important et nous allons vous diffuser
un reportage réalisé grâce aux nouvelles
installations de satellite franco
américain jr téléspectateurs vous
pardonnerez aisément cette émission
c'est un don vous pardonnera aisément
mon émotion car c'est la première fois
ce soir que nous allons avoir en direct
grâce aux procédés ont refusé mondiale
de télévision posséder mondiaux visuel
et voici une écoute
oui je vous savez très bien que c'est
très très difficile le procédé est
entièrement nouveau et il faut quand
même
rendre hommage aux techniciens qui ont
fait un match plein fort finck ce soir
nous ayons new york en direct chez vous
de toute façon comme ça c'est très très
loin et enfin il faut qu'une image
arrivent jusqu'à nous jusqu'au poste de
télévision et c'est très très difficile
c'est ce qui s'appelle un procédé
périlleux en fait c'est sa voix voilà
bien je crois que nous allons je crois
que nous allons voir new york
non nous n'aurons pas vous savez que ces
rois transmis de new study for par le
studio pour retourner l'espère mais je
pense que d'ici quelques instants
voilà non ça n'est pas non pas que ça
n'est pas new york et bien si vous le
permettez
j'ai vu les lacs de l'élever si ces
chalets
et c'est glaciers on a donc là on n'a
pas nous encore non j'ai vu les lacs de
l'italie et venise et ses gondolier on
n'a pas le coup ne le dirai quand on
aura lucas